It's January 13th,
2019.
Happy New Year to you all and thank you
for joining the
q and a.
so,
um,
I'll start with a couple of
announcements.
The first I suppose is that I'm leaving
Patrion January 15th.
Some of you may know that that's,
I suppose,
in protest over their treatment of Carl
Benjamin,
a perhaps better known as Sargon of a
cad I'm patron like many companies seems
to believe that their role now is to act
as sensor for speech patterns or speech
content that they regard as
unacceptable.
And uh,
I think that they made a big mistake
with Sargon and so both Dave Rubin and I
and also Sam Harris have decided to
leave patron and that's going to be
official as of January 15th.
So those of you who are my patron on
subscribers,
if you're interested in continuing with
that subscription,
you can go to my website at Jordan b
Peterson Dotcom and there's a support
button there,
uh,
in the menu and you can use that system.
I'm also trying to design a system that,
at least in principle,
might work as a reasonable replacement
for patriotic.
That's a couple of months away,
but we're working hard on it.
We're getting legal advice.
We're going to set up multiple payment
channels so that it won't be easy for
people to be kicked off by credit card
companies or let's call them virtue
signaling a ethical types who think that
their role is to police free speech.
So I think this is a very bad precedent
that patronage is set and the credit
card companies to.
I can't imagine it's difficult to
imagine a more dystopian scenario than
to have the large tech companies in
combination with the credit card
companies monitor your spending to
decide when what you're doing is
sufficiently ethical by their,
by the standards of the people who are
running their,
let's call them safety and security
speech monitoring programs.
It's just such a terrible idea.
So there's that,
um,
that I'm also working on my new book
quite a lot,
but actually,
um,
it's tentatively titled Beyond Order
Twelve more rules for life or perhaps
beyond mere order.
I haven't decided on that yet.
I can tell you what the rules are.
Maybe you'd be interested in that.
So I'll give you a list of them.
The first one is,
do not carelessly denigrates social
institutions or creative achievement
rule to imagine who you could be and
then aim singlemindedly at that.
Rule three,
work as hard as you can,
work as hard as you possibly can on at
least one thing and see what happens.
Rule four,
do not hide unwanted things in the fog
rule five,
abandoned ideology,
abandoned ideology.
Rule six,
notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated.
Rule seven,
do not do things that you hate.
Rule eight,
try to make one room in your house as
beautiful as possible.
Rule Nine,
if all memories still make you cry,
right them down carefully and
completely.
Rule Ten.
Plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance in your relationship.
Rule Eleven,
be grateful in spite of your suffering.
And then rule 12,
do not allow yourself to become
resentful,
deceitful,
or arrogant.
In principle,
that book will be published in January
20 slash 20.
So,
and I'm supposed to have the manuscript
and sometime within the next six months
and I have a first draft done and I'm
working hard on the repeated edits,
um,
it's going to be published similar in
the UK and the US and Canada.
Um,
I'm working with three different editors
and so that's that part of the
announcement and so I'm hoping,
I'm really hoping that I can make the
next book better.
Like it would be a pair,
it'll be a paired copy with the first
one.
I'm probably going to publish it with a
black cover to go with the white cover
of 12 rules and I'm hoping that I can
make it into a better book and that the
two together will make a very complete
set.
So that's the plan.
We'll see how it goes.
The last announcement,
I guess.
No,
two more announcements.
I'm going to Switzerland tomorrow.
Um,
my daughter's having surgery there to
get her ankle fixed again.
We're hoping that that will go well.
I'm also doing a talk in Zurich and I
have three talks in California.
Information for them,
Miss Jordan,
b Peterson,
dark com forward slash events.
And then in February,
my wife and I are going,
my wife,
Tammy and I are going to Australia,
New Zealand and I believe we have 15,
a talk scheduled there over the course
of about a month.
And then I think in March and April I'm
going to concentrate mostly on writing
and then perhaps we're going to go to
Europe.
And so that's for a month or two that
will depend to some degree on the
writing schedule,
but that's the plan at the moment.
I have some good podcasts up.
I talked to General Stanley mcchrystal
last week about his new book on
leadership and the myths that surround
it,
um,
and some of the initiatives that he's
been working on in the United States.
And so what crystal was the commander of
the American forces in Afghanistan.
And so it was very interesting to talk
to him.
And uh,
well there's a variety of other things
going on too,
but I won't tell you anymore about those
for the time being.
I think what I'll do instead is turning
to some questions.
So,
um,
I guess maybe I could also give a bit of
a recap for 2018,
so tammy and I have gone to about 115
cities now,
something like that.
Her Google a trip trackers showed that
she had gone six times around the world
mindset 20.
And so that's obviously wrong because I
traveled mostly with her,
but there was a lot of traveling last
year I spoke to about 250,000 people and
that was a very,
all of that was very positive
experience.
The lectures have been really,
um,
well,
heart warming to use an old term.
I mean it's really something to see that
many people gathered together and,
and listen and,
and,
and participate in a discussion about
about
psychological and philosophical and
spiritual issues that as deep as I can
manage anyways,
and it seems to be quite gripping for
the audience and good for everyone.
And so they're very,
very positive experiences,
which is partly why we've been able to
sustain this speaking pace.
So that's been good.
Oh,
we also have a discount by the way.
My partners and I decided to,
um,
encourage everybody to make their new
year's resolutions in a sophisticated
and comprehensive way.
And so we have this program,
some of you have heard about
this@selfauthoring.com called future
authoring.
And the future authoring program helps
you write out a vision for the future to
think through what you'd like your life
to be like if you were taking care of
yourself properly,
to consider your friends and your family
and your career and your education and
your use of time outside of work and
your ability to resist temptation,
that kind of temptation that might drag
you down and a
and how you might take care of yourself
mentally and physically.
And to write about that.
And then to write a counter,
a story which was where you might be
three to five years down the road if you
let all your bad habits get out of
control.
And then to write a strategic plan.
It's a very useful program.
We've used it with lots of university
students in particular,
although it's for,
for adults of all ages.
Um,
and if you're a university student and
you complete the program,
it seems to increase the probability
that you'll stay in university by about
25 percent,
something like that.
Um,
it seems particularly useful by the way,
for men,
for reasons that we don't exactly
understand,
maybe because they're underperforming
women academically and it also improves
people's grades,
but there's a large literature in the
industrial organizational area also
indicating that if you're,
like,
if you're working and you make a
personal plan of this sort and your
overall productivity increases by about
10 percent,
which is a lot and you're,
you're more likely to be physically and
mentally healthy.
And so I would really recommend trying
this.
Even you can try the program.
You don't have to do a perfect job at
it.
It doesn't really matter because you're
trying to set out a bit of a vision and
a plan for your life and you need that
because you need direction and you need
purpose and you need the constraints of
a vision to help you be less anxious and
uncertain.
And,
and you,
you have that anxiety and uncertainty
reduction does occur.
If you have a decent map of where it is
that you're headed,
the coupon code is [inaudible] 2019,
New Year's 2019 and why 2019.
And if you go to the self authoring site
and click on the product's a menu item
and go to future author and you could
just enter in that coupon code and it's
50 percent off.
So I think the total price is $7 and
forty five cents,
which is actually pretty damn cheap.
If what it does is help structure your
future.
And I really do think this is a helpful
program.
We've worked on it a lot and tested lot
and it's based on solid behavioral
psychological principles.
Lie with I would say a certain degree
of,
of optimistic philosophy.
And it's,
well
it's a good thing to do
and um,
this is a good time to do it.
So if you're interested,
all that information will be in the
description of the video as well.
So that's basically that.
Um,
as far as I can tell,
I don't think I have anything else to
tell you.
Oh,
I'm 12 rules for life has sold about 3
million copies now.
So I guess I'm telling you that,
uh,
it's become very popular in Korea where
it sold about 200,000 copies,
which is quite interesting in something
I wouldn't have necessarily expected.
So.
Alright.
So let's answer some questions and see
how that goes.
Can you talk about your own specific
experiences slash methods used with
integrating the shadow?
Yeah,
well I can actually,
I think a tremendous amount of what you
might regard as shadow integration,
which in the parlance of behavioral
psychologists would be something like
assertiveness training,
right?
It's training and how to stand up for
yourself and for your,
let's say for your better self,
which would be the self that you can use
productively over a medium to long
period of time that would be of use to
you,
but also views to people around you.
So it's a self that's founded by the
necessity of taking care of yourself,
but also simultaneously taking care of
the people around you.
Um,
I think that the simplest way to start
that work is to consult your resentment.
You know,
it's easy to become bitter about life
and to become angry because of course
life is difficult and it's full of
disappointments and people are also
subject to be trail on the part of
themselves and the people that
hypothetically care for them.
And so it's easy to get bitter and to be
resentful and resentment is a very
useful emotion even though I think it's
one of the most,
uh,
damaging emotions if it's not dealt with
properly.
So if you're resentful basically means
only one of two things,
it either means you should grow up and
quit whining and get on with your life
or it means that you're being subject to
tyrannical forces of one form or another
maybe emanating from you.
Maybe a consequence of the natural
environment,
maybe a consequence of society.
You're being subject to tyrannical
forces and you're not putting your own
best interests forward.
Like in that broader sense that I
described.
And I don't mean you're selfish,
narrow interests that only serve the
purposes of instantaneous gratification.
I mean your own best interest in terms
of developing your character over the
span of your life.
If you're resentful,
it either means that you're immature and
that you should grow the hell up,
and so you need to figure out how much
of your resentment is is is that and
maybe allied with the desire to find
other things or people to blame,
but the other possible option is that
you have something to say or do,
right?
Because you're in a situation where
you're violating your own internal
ethical standards and you're being
required pressure,
let's say to say things you don't
believe or to do things that you believe
to be wrong and you need to determine.
You need to start to strategize and plan
how you can rectify that so that you can
say what you mean.
Like if you're negotiating with a
marital partner,
for example,
and there are issues in your marriage
that aren't making you happy.
Well,
the first thing is you have to take note
of that,
right?
To see that you're actually unhappy.
Uh,
the second is that you have to be
willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to sort out
what's disturbing you,
you're going to have to lay your
concerns out on the table and say,
well look,
this is bothering me.
You don't have to say,
well,
I'm right and you're wrong and you have
to fix this.
You have to say,
well,
I've noticed that this
pattern of interaction or lack of
interaction say in our relationship is
making me resentful and angry,
and the danger of that of course,
is you're going to take it out on
yourself and your partner,
the Dangerous Passion,
passive aggressiveness.
You know,
you're not going to respond to your
partner positively when they do
something good if you're resentful about
and you're not going to respond to
yourself properly.
So you have to lay it out on the table.
But sort of in a spirit of ignorance,
humility.
It's like,
look,
I'm frustrated.
I'm feeling this way about our
relationship.
Here's what I think might be going
wrong.
Maybe on my part and maybe on your part
and here's what I envisioned as a
possible solution.
That's also really necessary if you're
going to say what you have to say,
which is to manifest yourself properly
in the world is you can't just complain
about what's wrong.
You have to think,
well,
what would my minimal preconditions for
satisfaction be?
You have to offer that to the person
that you're negotiating with and so then
you learn to abide by the truth to the
degree that you can do that and no one
does it perfectly.
No,
but it's very useful because you're not
storing up a whole sequence of memories
about how you were unfairly treated and
abused and betrayed.
Instead,
you're trying to stay on top of it and
to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself
and to accept that that's the case and
then to analyze that to see if it's your
problem.
Like I said,
with regards to maturity or if it
indicates that there's an injustice in
the manner in which you and the world
are interacting and then to work to set
that right even in small ways and so
it's a matter of character,
logical development,
and that makes you.
That makes you stronger over time and
partly what you need,
you know,
in order to do that is you have to
really understand,
and we do this.
This is why we built in the future
authoring program.
We built this section where you have to
outline your most dismal future,
right?
What your future would be like if you
let all your bad habits and
characterological weaknesses have the
upper hand.
And the reason we did this is because
you can't be a.
You can't straighten yourself out merely
as a consequence of hope.
Let's say you lay out a vision for the
future and you think about what your
life would be,
what,
what you'd like your life to be like,
and then that makes you hopeful and it
motivates you because it gives you
something worthwhile and higher order to
work for.
Right?
And that's useful,
that's positive emotion working for you
because positive emotion is experienced
in relationship to goals,
but it's not as not as useful as also
being chased by something you're
terrified by and if you have a good
sense of how you'd fall apart,
if you stayed week and just exactly what
kind of hell that would be.
Then when you determined to do something
like to tell the truth and to say what
you think and to not do things that you
hate,
then you're going to be pulled along by
the purpose that your vision has
provided for you,
but also pushed along by your desire to
avoid the worst forms of hail that
you've already outlined for yourself
personally.
And that can also help you be brave
enough to stand up in a situation that
we would require a conflict.
Because if you have something to say and
you have something to negotiate about
with someone,
then there's going to be a certain
amount of conflict.
Jewel dialogue,
um,
that accompanies that right to,
to lay out a set of problems and to
describe the fact forthrightly that
those problems characterize a
relationship.
And then to seek for solutions is quite
stressful in the short term and it's
really easy to avoid and so people
avoided all the time and then they store
up grievances across the span of the
relationships and eventually the
grievances mount to the point where they
return in monstrous forum and just eat
everything up.
That's where you get divorces or that's
where you explode at your boss and ended
up fired or that's where you know you
develop high blood pressure over 15
years because he can't stand all the
accumulated a monster,
all the accumulated monsters in your
closet and then you drink yourself into
oblivion because he can't stand to your
life.
That's all you know.
Very counterproductive,
but it's easy to avoid that necessary
conflict on a moment to moment basis
because it's very stressful to speak
forthrightly about genuine conflicts,
especially when you're dealing with
important parts of your life.
But otherwise you don't straighten them
out and then you have to carry all that
forward.
So you need to be terrified of the
consequences of not speaking your piece.
And that can counterbalance the terror
of actually trying to have a
conversation so well,
you know,
and you also have to look with regards
to the shadow ideas like you have to get
in touch with the depths of your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful about all
sorts of things.
They're resentful about old women and
they're resentful about men and they're
resentful about the patriarchy and
they're resentful about the left wing
and resentful about the right wing and
the resentful about politicians and
they're resentful about the,
like the cataclysmic force of nature and
its ability to make people sick and,
and suffer.
And they are resentful about their own
inadequacies in the boat.
They're bad parenting and God like the
list is just bloody endless.
And that can make you very,
very angry.
And that's part of that resentment and
cynical and bitter and dark and full of
fantasies about destruction and the
desire to bring things down and the wish
that everyone else suffered.
And the desire to shake your fist at
God.
And all of that's really dark.
You know,
young said,
well,
the shadow human shout,
it extends all the way down to hell and
he really meant that,
you know,
because all the terrible things that
people are motivated to do are
associated with that shadow domain and
like none of you are any,
none of you are saints in any
likelihood.
You have a terrible capacity for
destructiveness.
And when you start to consult your
resentment and to see how angry you are,
it can terrify you to see the depths of
that anger.
Sometimes that'll manifest itself in
very destructive fantasies.
You know,
um,
which you might not want to become
conscious of because they're so.
I'm brutal,
let's say.
And so aggressive that you can't even
believe that you generate them the nice
person that's you.
It's like,
so it's quite frightening to open the
door and see all that.
And that also associates you with the
entire dark shadow of mankind,
right?
The sate,
tannic element of the human character.
And but it opens the door to
understanding as well,
to,
to understanding how people can do
terrible things because you could see
yourself as one of the people who could
do terrible things.
That's really useful,
you know,
because then you.
Well then maybe you start to be
motivated to be the sort of person who
wouldn't do terrible things.
You know,
if you can really come to terms with the
fact that that's part and parcel of you.
It also is some in perverse sense.
It's also a discovery of your own
strength though,
because you know,
if you have that desire for aggression,
that desire for destruction and that,
that,
that ability to fantasize in that
aggressive manner,
it also means that you can incorporate
some of that into your speech and into
your actions so that you're a lot more
immovable,
right?
And,
and a lot more of a force to contend
with.
It can give you some respect for
yourself when you realize that you're a
force of destruction as well as
creation.
And then you're also more likely to
treat yourself with a bit more
intelligent caution.
You know,
to know that you're a part of you is a
ticking bomb in some sense that could go
off and so you,
you,
you try a bit more lightly around
yourself and had maybe you encourage
people to tread more lightly around you
as well,
which isn't such a bad thing and all the
people that I really admire that I know
have a clearly dangerous side and you
don't want to get,
you don't want to have that activated
any more than necessary,
but it's also what makes them
respectable and strong,
especially if they have that under
control.
So,
oh,
that's a bit of a dialogue about shadow
integration.
It's a very
challenging undertaking,
you know,
to pull in that dark side of your
character and that would be all the
things that you've repressed or failed
to develop as a consequence of trying to
be a harmless.
And
uh,
well let's say a harmless and
harmless citizen who looks virtuous.
The surface,
that's the union persona.
And you need that because everybody
needs a mask that they wear in public,
like a suit,
you know,
so that we can tolerate seeing each
other on the street.
We don't have to look right into our
depths every time we interact,
we need that persona.
But that has to be transcended.
And the way to transcend that is to
integrate the darker parts of the
character.
They're very useful.
That aggression,
that sexual demand,
for example,
all of that very difficult to socialize
that competitiveness,
but unbelievably useful in terms of
force of character,
if you can manage it.
Richard asked,
how can I help my parents to sort
themselves out?
That's question one.
How can I talk about the resentments of
my childhood in a way that benefits them
instead of giving them guilt?
Yeah.
Well,
those are two very difficult questions.
How can you help your parents to sort
themselves out?
Well,
I guess the first question would be,
do they want to sort themselves out
because it's not that easy to help
people if they don't want to be helped.
If they do want to be helped.
Like listening is really a good
strategy.
Um,
you know,
people,
you got the question right,
because you said,
how can I help my parents to sort
themselves out,
which is very different than how can I
sort my parents out.
You help people to sort themselves out
once they have decided to do so by
giving them the opportunity to talk
about their concerns and also to outline
what potential solutions might be and
you don't want to offer too many pieces
of advice while you're doing that
because it turns out that people are
much more likely to implement a strategy
of improvement if they generate it
themselves.
And then also you don't steal the
accomplishment from them.
Like let's say you came to me with a
bunch of problems and I said,
well,
here's what you can do about that.
And then you went out and did it and it
worked.
And then in some sense that's not your
accomplishment.
I mean it is in so far as you
implemented,
but it's not in so far as it was
something that I planned.
And your intimation of that,
your integration of the fact that the
delight in success in the responsibility
for six success might have been stolen
from you by well meaning advice is going
to interfere with the probability that
you'll implement the solution.
And so it's best to let people talk
through their own problems like,
well,
what's the problem?
What you asked,
What do you think is not right about
your life?
And then people will throw out a bunch
of things that they're complaining about
or resentful about and it might be quite
an extensive list and they'll feel
guilty about it because they don't want
to burden you with it,
but they need to it all off their chest,
right?
They need to get the cards on the table.
It's also something to know when you're
talking to your wife or your husband or
your intimate partner or child for that
matter.
So when you have a close relationship
with this,
if they've got some things to complain
about,
which they undoubtedly do,
they're going to complain about a lot
more things than they're actually upset
about because they'll have gathered up
irritations that have been unspoken and
aggravations and fears and they'll all
be upsetting them emotionally and they
don't know exactly what they are until
they articulate that,
you know,
we say,
well,
what are you upset about?
Well,
I don't know.
how can you not know?
Well,
the answer is there's all sorts of
things that you respond to emotionally
before you can articulate them.
Then you get upset and you explode and
you yell and you lay out all the things
you might be angry about and you're
impulsive and you overstate your case
and you accused people of things that
you don't even believe.
All of that's part of the process of
laying your cards out on the table.
You have complex situations that are
disturbing you and you don't know what
they are.
And exactly you have to kind of guess.
So you say,
well,
it might be this and it might be that,
and it might be this,
it might be you,
and this is why it's your fault.
You get accused and then if you're
listening to all that,
you have to just be patient and let the
person get all their cards out on the
table.
Even if some of that involves
accusations about you,
which you don't have to immediately.
You don't have to immediately jumped to
the conclusion that those accusations
are accurate to that you have to defend
yourself.
You know,
I'm not,
believe me,
I'm not saying this is easy because it's
not,
but you listen to the person lay out
their their deck of complaints and the
first thing you'll find is that they
will take 50 percent or maybe more 75
percent of the cards off the table right
away.
Because once they've articulated out
those concerns,
they'll find that they're not really
central.
They're not really the issue.
And so that leaves a smaller number of
genuine problems.
And then you can ask people again,
well,
here's the problem.
Can you think of any way?
If you could conceptualize how things
would be better in relationship to that
problem,
well,
what would a solution look like even in
principle and then they might say,
well,
I don't know,
and then they have to guess and lay
their cards out on the table about what
a solution might look like if they say
they don't know that often means they
don't want to think about it and a
little bit of encouragement isn't in
order and maybe a little bit of
pressure,
um,
but you want people to formulate a
vision of what the situation would look
like if the problem was solved.
And then they might find it very
daunting because the solution looks so
difficult that they don't see any
pathway to it.
And so then the next part of the
discussion is,
well,
are there some things that you could do
that would be small steps that you would
be interested in doing that you think
you would do that would move you to the
solution?
And maybe those things could be
implemented.
Tentatively behavioral psychologists
call that collaborative empiricism.
So you'll come and see a behavioral
psychologist and lay out your problems
and then the two of you will negotiate
towards,
uh,
the beginnings of a solution.
What could you do this week that might
make that problem slightly better?
And so you talked through what's
practical and what's implementable,
and you have to be honest about that
because you don't want to set yourself
up with a plan that's so complicated.
You won't implement it.
Then you say to the person,
if you're the psychologist,
you say,
well look,
we've got a couple of ideas about what
you could do this week that might make
this situation slightly better.
Why don't you go and implement them and
then come back next week and we'll talk
about whether or not that worked and
work would be you did implement it and
that it did have the desired solution.
And if it didn't work,
meaning you didn't implement it or the
solution didn't emerge,
then there's,
there's the opportunity for
renegotiation.
So you can think about it strategically.
The first issue is if something needs to
be sorted out,
the first question is what the Hell's
the problem?
And the answer to that is you probably
don't know.
The problem is I'm upset and disturbed
and angry and resentful and bitter and
unhappy and anxious and in pain and
lonesome,
I'm suffering from an excess of negative
emotion and perhaps from a certain
amount of hopelessness.
So the problem is the emotional
circumstance and that might be
associated with some real problems,
right?
Some real practical problems.
So you lay all that out and say,
okay,
well what is the problem landscape look
like?
Right?
So that's the strategic move.
And then,
as I said,
that will generally simplify the problem
landscape.
Then you do the same thing with a set of
potential solutions.
Well,
what would the solutions look like
because you're not gonna be able to
solve a problem unless you at least know
what a solution might look like.
That would actually,
um,
what would you say that would,
that you would find acceptable?
And then the next issue is to lay out
the strategies for the attainment of
that solution.
And you know,
sometimes it might be,
some of these solutions might be dismal.
Like,
you know,
if you've got someone who's ill in your
family to solution might be,
well,
well we need a cure.
You know,
that's the only solution that will
suffice,
but you don't know how to pursue the
cure or maybe one doesn't exist.
So then you have to think of,
well,
a lower order and less satisfying
solution,
which would be,
well maybe we can cope.
We're going to learn to cope with this
so that it's the least amount of hell
possible.
And,
and maybe that maybe that even that's
too much.
You might have to say,
well,
we're going to try to make this next
week when we're coping with this better
than the last week.
You know?
And,
and maybe you can't even do that.
It has to just be the next day.
You look for whatever small steps
forward you can take that will make
things less wretched and horrible than
they currently are.
You know,
to put it rather bluntly.
And that requires the willingness to
face the problem,
the humility to know that you don't have
the solution at hand.
The willingness to listen to how the
other people that you're talking to
formulate the problems and formulate the
solutions.
It's crucially important,
right?
To have them do that work themselves.
It's also,
you could think about it this way too,
is that if you listen to someone come up
with a solution,
you don't undergo with the neurological
transformation necessary to change your
character,
but if you come up with the solutions
yourself,
you know if you articulate the problem
and you articulate the solutions,
then you've changed your own character
in a way that increases the probability
that you're going to act out what you do
and that requires real patients to to
let people stumble through to their own
problems.
Solutions because someone might lay out
a set of problems and you think,
oh my God,
I know what you could do about that,
but it doesn't really matter if you
know.
You know,
and I'm also not saying that sometimes
advice is helpful.
You know,
sometimes you can give someone a hint,
but man,
you have to be careful with that because
there's a real element of theft that's
associated with it.
Now Richard also asked,
how can I talk about the resentments of
my childhood in a way that benefits them
instead of giving them guilt?
I don't know if I can answer that
question,
Richard,
because it's not a question.
That's what I would ask.
If you came to talk to me and you had
that question,
I would say first of all,
well what resentments?
List them out,
man.
Write him down.
Okay,
so that you know what they are.
Because all of those,
each of those resentments is going to be
a different thing and the strategy
that's associated with each might vary
as a consequence of the particularity of
the resentment.
So I would say you should start by
writing them down like,
what's your problem exactly here?
Here's all the things that I can think
of that I'm angry about with regard to
my childhood.
Write that down and then see which ones
are are still living,
and then you have to figure out,
well,
what do you want from your parents?
Exactly.
Do you.
Do you want them to apologize?
Do you want them to understand what they
did wrong?
Do you want to punish them?
Do you want to get?
Let them get you.
Let them learn to know you better.
Do you want to change the way they're
interacting with you now?
Do you want to learn your own lessons
from your bad experience so that when
you're a parent,
you don't make the same mistake.
You merely want to have a chance to
express yourself like it's very
difficult to.
To answer your question because I don't
know what your goal is,
right?
So we bought an and I don't need to
know.
You need to know what are the
resentments so we can walk the process
we already described laid them out and
comprehensively you might want to make a
list of everything that you think you
might conceivably be annoyed about with
regards to your parents.
No matter how trivial,
right?
Because that way you you scour your
memory for,
for,
for things that you're holding onto in a
bitter way and maybe you have your
justification.
I'm not suggesting that you don't,
but you need to discover what baggage
you're carrying.
Then you have to figure out,
well,
what can I let go of and what's core,
and I would say what's really core is
if there are ways that your parents
treated you that are still affecting you
or that are affecting your relationships
with them now,
those really need to be dealt with
because they're not done.
They're not in the past.
They're not even resentments of your
childhood.
They're still part of your ongoing life
and so,
okay,
so now you have all your resentments
laid out.
I guess I would say,
you know,
something like,
look,
mom and dad,
there's something I need to talk to you
about that's been bothering me for a
long time,
and I picked one of the more trivial
things to begin with.
It's like,
here's a memory I have and don't get all
high and mighty about it because you
know,
you might have misconstrued the
situation as a child.
It's highly probable and they may have
had their reasons and you may not even
remember the situation,
let's say correctly or the way they
remembered saying,
well,
here's,
here's something that happened when I
was a kid in it.
It still bothers me in,
do you remember what happened?
That's an open ended question.
Do you remember what happened?
Why did this,
where did this go this way?
And then I will do an awful lot of
listening,
you know,
because you are trying to gather
information and the more your parents
can tell you about what happened in
those situations,
I would say the better off you're likely
to be.
So that's about all I can say about
that.
That's fairly delineated approach to
general discussions about difficult
things,
right?
But I would say don't be afraid of,
don't be more afraid of engaging in this
process.
Then you are afraid of not engaging in
it.
Like every relationship you have is
going to have problems in it.
And you know,
you don't want to jump to a intense
psychological discussion with every
little bump.
But if,
if there's something,
um,
medium to longterm permanence that's
disturbing you,
or a pattern that repeats itself at
least three times,
let's say,
well then that might be something that's
worthy of discussion or your discovery
that you're very dissatisfied with the
way the relationship is going and you
have to have the conflict necessary to
sort that out and it's going to be
conflict with you and the client and the
person that you're talking to.
But the aim should be the establishment
of something like fully informed,
fully negotiated medium to longterm
piece.
That's what you're aiming at.
If you have any sense.
Oh,
cody said it took me seven months,
but I completed all the self authoring
suit in July.
I'm still not motivated to do anything
and waste all of my time.
What do I do?
Well?
Well,
the first question is,
is it true that you're not motivated to
do anything?
And is it true that you waste all of
your time?
It seems highly unlikely to me that both
of those things are 100 percent true.
So one of the things you might notice is
are there anything,
is there anything that you're motivated
to do,
presume you're motivated to eat or the
perhaps not,
and I'm not being smart about this.
Partly what I would say is two things.
He might need some smaller goals.
Like you have to shrink your goals to
the point where you've established a
plan forward that consists of steps that
not only you would be willing to take
but that you would take.
And so some of that is humility.
It's like,
man,
I'm stuck.
I can barely do anything and it's okay,
well I'm,
I'm laying in bed for seven hours a day.
Well,
could I lay in bed for six hours,
six and a half hours tomorrow,
you know,
or while I'm in bed,
could I do something somewhat useful?
Could I read a book?
Can I read one page of a book?
Can I read a paragraph of a book?
You have to find that those steps
forward that you wouldn't take.
I really think it's useful to make
friends with something like a Google
calendar,
you know,
or whatever calendar program you might
want to use and start designing days
that you would like to have because
that's the right way to use a calendar
and everyone out there that's listening.
You should.
You should use a calendar to structure
your days because if you know what
you're doing tomorrow,
it decreases your anxiety substantially
because you need that kind of structure.
You need a pathway,
you need to know,
you need to have a map and you need to
know where you're located on the map and
you need to know how you're moving
forward and that gives you hope because
you're moving towards goals that you
regard as worthwhile and it stops you
from being anxious because you're not
entirely directionless and lost and so
learning how to manage your time is
useful and you can start with a
calender.
You can start with simple things like
you can put in well when you're likely
to go to bed and when you're likely to
get up and and regulating.
That's useful.
That should be relatively
ritualistically consistent.
It's very difficult to get your life in
order if your sleep wake schedule is
completely a random or if it's not
aligned with like day and night and if
it's not aligned with the normative
practices of other people.
And so you may have to learn to get your
sleep,
wake cycle regulated properly,
and then the same with your eating
schedule.
Those are very basic things and you can
do that badly,
but that's what you want to approximate
three meals a day,
let's say,
because that's what people do
normatively.
And um,
and then you have to add small goals.
Now,
if that doesn't work,
like if you can't make the goals small
enough to achieve,
you know,
it might be that you're not being humble
enough with regards to your conceptions
of your own ability.
But you can tell if the goal that you
put forward is a reasonable one if
you're actually implementing it.
Because if you're not,
then by definition it's not a reasonable
goal.
You know,
like let's say you're,
you're sleeping all the time in your
room is just a bloody complete disaster,
you know,
and you think,
well I should clean up my room.
It's like,
well maybe you can't,
but maybe tomorrow you could hang up two
shirts,
you know,
or you could or you could move to shirts
from your bedroom to the laundry room or
you could bag up a bag of dirty clothes
that you could conceivably take to a
laundromat and just do that one thing.
You know,
if you do,
if the rooms that catastrophe and you do
that one thing and then you did one
thing like that for 15 days or 20 days,
maybe your place would be an order.
And so the trick is to get the
trajectory right.
And Cody,
if you,
if that doesn't work,
then you're going to need to talk to
somebody.
You know,
maybe you need a partner that,
that,
that you can discuss these things with
where you both have a commitment,
like a mutual commitment to attaining a
certain set of goals.
You know?
And that can be a friend.
It could be somebody that you find
online,
it could be,
and it could be a professional,
but if you find that you yourself
cannot,
you just can't get this going,
then you're going to have to reach out
to someone else to give you a hand.
Maybe you need to sit down with a parent
or a friend or somebody that you love
and go over the self authoring suite
with them to go over the future
authoring plans and to discuss how that
might be implemented.
You know,
because if you can't do it on your own
then and maybe you shouldn't have to,
then you have to reach out to other
people and so make your goals smaller.
See if you can make friends with a
schedule or a calendar.
This is really important.
All of you out there who aren't doing
this,
like I would say all of the people that
I know who have become successful in any
way use a structured means to organize
their time.
They have lists of things to do like
they have every day.
There's a list of things to do that day.
Every week there's a list of things to
do that week,
every month there's a list of things to
do that month,
you know,
at every level of temporal resolution
there's a sequence of plans and those
plans are implemented on a day to day
basis.
You cannot be an successful isn't the
right way of thinking about it because
I'm not thinking about,
you know,
I'm not really thinking about rising up
the corporate ladder.
You know what I mean?
And that's sort of what success has come
to mean in our culture that isn't what I
mean.
You can have a life that you're going to
find acceptable without that because you
need the vision and the plans to give
you purpose and direction.
That's where all your positive emotion
comes from.
All your motivation is laying out plans
that are worth attaining and then
observing yourself moving towards them.
That's the source of most positive
meaning.
And then also without that structure,
you're so lost that you're going to be
anxious and overwhelmed.
It's really like being in a foreign
country like isolated and alone with no
map.
I don't know where the hell I am.
I don't know what the hell I'm doing,
you know the rains are going to come,
the storms are going to come and maybe
it's winter and I don't know where I am
or where I'm going.
And then the last thing,
cody is like rely on some other people.
Man,
you know,
maybe you'll be able to return the favor
in the future.
I know you'll feel bad maybe that you
have to go to someone else.
You'll feel weak and you know that
you're taking advantage of them,
but people like to be helpful.
They really do.
And and so it's a mark of trust in
someone and confidence in them that you
would ask to have a serious conversation
with them and so and if you don't have
someone like that,
then you need to find somebody like that
and maybe that means you'll have to
interact more in online communities or
maybe you have to get the hell out there
in the world.
There's lots of meetup groups and that
sort of thing online that have organized
themselves and you can go there and hide
in the back for awhile.
Not Talk to anybody,
but you're going to get it.
I get the hell out there and,
and,
you know,
make some social connections because you
cannot live alone.
We're social creatures and you need help
and maybe you'll be able to offer some
help at some point in the future too.
So.
Well,
okay,
rose says,
I'm consumed by envy.
I can hardly stand to read or watch or
listen to anyone more successful than
myself.
In what directions am I aiming wrong?
Okay,
well,
look rose,
it's pretty damn useful to figure out
that you're consumed by envy.
That's a good start.
You know that.
That's a real self realization and an
important one.
Okay?
So the first thing we might ask is,
well,
um,
it's,
it's likely reasonable for you to
observe that that's not optimal for you,
right?
Because envy,
that's that resentment that I was
talking about earlier or even worse,
that jealousy.
It's like it's not a pleasant
phenomenological state.
It's not a pleasant state of experience.
Okay,
so look,
let's look at it this way.
Well,
what are you envious of?
You know,
you say,
I can hardly stand to read or watch or
listen to anyone more successful than
myself.
Well,
that's pretty vague,
rose,
and you want to tighten up your end via
bit.
It's like you'll find that there are
certain people that you're particularly
envious of and others whose
accomplishments really don't,
uh,
disturb you,
let's say.
So the first thing you want to do is
figure out which people it is that
you're particularly envious up.
And then you want to figure out,
well,
what is it that you think they have?
Now?
You know,
they probably have a lot more problems
than you think.
And so part of the pathology of envy is
that you look at someone who's
successful and you assume that that
success defines them across all the
important dimensions of their life.
And that's rarely the case.
And so,
you know,
there's a naive optimism and envy and
that's reflected in the fact that you
think that the person you're jealous of
has everything that a person would need.
And that's rarely the case,
but that's somewhat besides the point.
Look,
in your end,
the lurks,
the beginnings of a structure of
ambition.
You wouldn't be envious of something if
you didn't believe that that was a value
that you should possess.
Okay,
so the first thing is make a list of all
the people you're in vsl and then figure
out what it is about them that you envy.
Okay?
Now those are your goals.
All of a sudden,
right now,
you might be doubtful that you can
attain those goals and I don't know what
the goals would be.
You know,
like maybe it's beauty for God sake.
Maybe you're envious.
Maybe just for the sake of argument,
you assume that you're not a very good
looking person.
We can assume you're not blessed by the
same set of physical attributes that a
Hollywood star might manifest.
You know,
and maybe you're envious of that.
I was like,
well,
you might start to think,
well in first of all,
you might think about whether or not
there are dimensions of evaluation along
which someone might be judged that are
as important or more important than
physical attractiveness,
right?
Because there's multiple.
There's multiple dimensions along which
a person's positive attributes might be
rank ordered and considered,
so you might want to broaden out your
conceptualization of what constitutes
the good in human action,
but then like if it is a matter of
attractiveness,
then you may have to,
and I'm picking this one because it's a
particularly difficult one
attractiveness.
It's like,
well,
what could you do?
Like how often do you get your haircut
and is it flattering gift,
someone professional doing it?
Do you know how to use makeup properly
and carefully,
you know,
are you in reasonable physical condition
or are there,
are there steps that you could take to
put yourself in reasonable physical
condition?
Do you have some nice clothes like it's
a matter of decomposition,
so let's assume we'll be optimistic
about this.
You're envious.
Okay,
well that means there's some things you
value.
You don't have them,
but it's the beginnings of a
philosophical stance,
so you lay out what it is you're about
and you think,
well,
these persons,
these people have this and this and this
and this and I don't.
And that's unfair and it might be
unfair.
It's probably not an unfairness that
specifically aimed at you.
It's probably more a general reflection
of the unfairness and inequality that's
part of life and that's worth knowing,
but in any case,
you lay out your envy and you and you
delve deep into it and you find out,
well,
here's what I want because you're
envious,
envious because you see other people
that have what you want.
Okay,
good.
Now all of a sudden you know what you
want or that's useful,
terrifying,
because you might see that it's so
distant from you,
but you can at least lay out and then
maybe even admit to yourself what you
want.
Because the other thing is is that you'd
be unlikely to be so envious if you
weren't hiding from yourself.
What it is that you that you truly want.
You might be terrified to admit it
because,
well,
once you admit it,
then you know what you want and you know
when you're failing,
you know,
and and by hiding what you want from
yourself,
well then you can hide to some degree
the fact that you're not getting it and
that you're failing and it's no wonder
that people do that.
So make a list of what you're envious
of.
Extract from that the virtues that you
would like to pursue.
Understand clearly then,
unless you pursue those virtues,
you're not going to get what you want
and the envy will consume you more and
that's like a good pathway to hell.
That's not a good thing.
And so make a plan.
Here's some things that other people
have that I want.
How can I start to move towards having
some of that myself?
And that's a,
that's the right way to deal with it.
So because the other,
what's the alternative?
You're going to tear these people down
or or,
or,
or manifest hatred for,
for them and maybe take your revenge
when you can on the people around you
because you're so angry and you're going
to tear yourself into pieces,
like you said,
consumed by envy.
Right?
And,
and that,
that's like,
that's a Predator metaphor.
Envy is something that's eating you up
because that's not good,
you know,
but it's really good that you've at
least admitted it,
that start part of that confrontation
with his shadow.
So you can see your dark side there.
You know,
when you could look at your fantasies,
because if you're consumed by envy,
no doubt you have some pretty damn
brutal fantasies.
I wish this is what happened to that
person.
No God,
they think they're so smart and it's
like,
I hope they fall and I get a chance to
kick them well on debt.
Well,
they're down.
Maybe you can join a twitter mob and
take them out if they make a mistake,
you know,
but that can also get you in touch with
the dark side of you that maybe has the
ability to to put forward some
commitment to moving forward in the
future that can make you tough and
strong,
and so you might also start with the
consideration that you could move in the
direction that you desire,
right?
If you were willing to make the proper
sacrifices,
I'm willing to do the work and maybe if
you could find out what would truly
motivate you,
which might be the desire to cease being
consumed by envy,
that would be a good start.
And then to pursue these goals that are
implicit in your jealousy,
well then you have a direction for your
life.
So in what directions are you aiming
raw?
Well,
you're assuming that you're being
unfairly treated and that it's.
And that there's something personal
about that now you probably are being
unfairly treated in some sense because
that's just the human condition.
I would say like there's a real
arbitrary element of life.
You're subject to the depredations of
nature and the tyranny of culture and
your own appalling shortcomings,
you know,
and that's life.
It's not personal.
Exactly,
and that's worth knowing.
It's part of the standard human
condition and you should aim at
rectifying your envy and some of that's
going to be dropping that bitter
resentment and the other is going to be
pursuing what you need to pursue to
allow you to view your life as at least
acceptable.
Right?
So,
so there's hope in the NV once you admit
it,
because it gives you moral direction.
Hello,
Dr Peterson,
what would you advise to a person who
has the courage to defy the crowd but
doesn't have the verbal skills to debate
real time?
Well,
look,
there's lots of ways of defining the
crowd.
Let's say.
I mean you could live your life the way
that you want live id that's matter of
action and know,
and they say actions speak louder than
words,
and one of the best things you can
possibly be is a inspirational example.
So that's not nothing.
That's that something live properly in
your defiance of the crowd,
right?
Make your own course,
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles.
You don't necessarily have to advertise
that which is in some sense what you're
doing when you,
when you're debating because you're
taking the manner in which you act like
if you're an integrated person and
you're articulating that,
but maybe you can't do that because you
don't have the verbal skills.
Well then the question would be maybe
you should develop some more verbal
skills.
I'm like,
I don't know this for sure date if you
know,
but,
but generally it's useful.
How do you do that?
It doesn't hurt to read.
Really doesn't hurt to write,
you know,
a little bit of writing everyday
clarifies your thinking.
It's a hard thing to do and it's an
unlikely thing.
Most people won't do it,
but man,
you know,
you wouldn't be asking me this question
if you didn't think at some level that
some improvement in your verbal ability
would be useful to you.
Also,
how do you do that?
You read,
you think you're right.
The reason you write is because writing
forces you to articulate your thoughts
and organize your brain around whatever
it is that you're writing about.
And then one of the easiest ways to
write there isn't any real easy way,
but when the easiest ways to write is to
write down a problem,
it's like,
well,
what's,
what,
what problem is bothering me?
Or you can write about that.
First of all to get the problem clear
because that's a hard thing.
Then you start to write about what my
possible solutions be and if you fight
with those solutions because you know,
you want to kill off the stupid ones and
then,
you know,
maybe you need to learn to speak more
fluently.
Maybe you need to,
um,
what,
what might we say?
You could try a class in improvisation
and maybe that's too daunting.
You could join a speaker's club like
toastmasters.
Um,
you could try talking more at dinner
parties a little bit more.
Once you formulate your thoughts,
you have to be willing to be somewhat of
a bumbling fool to begin with,
right?
Because you're gonna not if and maybe
you're better,
your verbal skills are better than you
think they are,
you know,
and you're just self conscious,
but you have to practice putting
yourself forward a little bit and tended
to flee.
You can do a lot of that,
you know,
a lot of that initial learning how to
interact with people though,
by asking them questions about what they
think and then responding instead of
being too concerned about putting your
own point forward.
So,
all right,
so what's the answer?
What would I advise to the person who
has the courage to defy the crowd?
Good.
Live according to your principles,
right?
And that's not a verbal thing and you
can be a good example and now it's a
major accomplishment.
But then if you need to improve your
verbal ability,
which is generally a good thing,
then those are the ways to do it.
Read,
write,
speak,
and,
and understand that developing those
abilities might be of tremendous use to
you.
You know,
because it's one thing to live properly
and that's not a trivial thing,
but it's another thing to be able to
articulate yourself and to be able to
negotiate and generally speaking,
there's nothing about that that isn't
advantageous and even introverted and
anxious people can learn to do that.
You know,
it's.
Those are learnable skills.
It's not easy but,
but,
but you can manage it.
You can also.
You can also speak carefully.
You know,
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true.
That's also unbelievably useful.
You have to feel that out.
Like,
is this really what I believe or am I
putting it forward because I want to
look good or I want to dominate or,
or I wanted to express bleakly and
emotion that I'm too cowardly to come
out and confront directly.
Or Am I being manipulative?
There's lots of reasons that people use
language,
but what you really should use it for is
to state what you believe to be true and
then to let the consequences of that
unfold and so that can also help you.
Simple truths,
bluntly stated,
can be very powerful.
You don't need a lot of verbal fluency
under those circumstances if there's
evidence of strength of character behind
it.
So
the Dao de Jing speaks of acting
naturally well,
I don't know if that's true.
If it's acting naturally.
It depends on what you mean by naturally
the Tao Te Ching speaks of acting in a
manner that balances Yin and Yang,
the balances chaos and order,
and that means that you're speaking in
the right place at the right time about
the right things,
and that's allied with part of what I
just discussed with regards to speaking
the truth.
How is one to put their foot down and
change slash better their condition
without an unnaturally manipulating
their world?
Well,
the fundamental answer to that is to
speak the truth and to let
the consequences of that unfold,
but then the trick is,
well,
how is it that you come to speak the
truth?
Well,
in order to do that,
as far as I can tell,
you have to be terrified of the
consequences of not speaking the truth.
And and part of that is,
well,
look,
do you want the truth on your side or
not?
Do you want to?
Do you want to be facing the truth as an
enemy?
Or do you want to have the truth behind
you as an ally?
And the truth is reality.
And I don't see that you want reality as
an enemy.
And so if what you do is use your
language to represent reality as
accurately as you possibly can.
Now given all your inadequacies and
biases,
you're bound to make errors.
But that's the goal.
Then you have the force of reality
behind you.
It's,
it's as if you've you know where you
are.
You might not like it and you may be,
you know,
maybe it's a terrible craggy chasm full
of lava and water,
but at least you can see where the
obstacles are and you can pick your way
through it.
So and then the naturalness is well
from the Dallas perspective.
In some sense you're,
you're,
you're aiming at being at peace with the
world.
And that means accepting it in some
sense for what it is.
And you can't speak the truth unless
you're willing to do that.
And that means to a large degree,
it means all,
it means exploring the depths of Yin and
Yang of order and chaos,
the order to know that like there are
tyrannical forces afoot and some of them
are operated in you and some of them
operate in the social world and,
and some of them operate for that matter
in the natural world,
too much crushing order.
And on the chaotic side,
there's the possibility of nihilism and
hopelessness and depression and that
complete cataclysm.
And so you're,
you're,
there's cliffs on both sides of you and
you have to be aware of that because you
don't want to fall into those cliffs and
there's a thin pathway between them that
you can,
that you can walk down if you're careful
and you feel your way down that pathway
by noting how,
what you say,
noting whether what you say puts a
foundation underneath you that that's,
there's a New Testament,
um,
injunction to that goal to build your
house on a rock not on sand.
And what's the rock or the rock is the
truth and integrity of your character
and have your voice.
That's what it is and why you see
you want to aim at something noble.
That's the alliance with God.
That's one way of thinking about it.
You want to serve the highest good and
you have to think very hard about what
that is.
I mean,
we know what it is to some degree or we
have some.
We have some collective conception of
that.
You know,
it would be piece.
That would be something.
It would be the willingness and desire
to treat other people like you would
like to be treated if you were treating
yourself properly.
It's that as well.
It's it's characterological nobility.
It's the desire to serve the good.
It's truth and beauty and all of those
classic virtues all integrated into a
single thing.
You want to serve that and then you and
then having aimed at that you won't do
and that,
that,
that governs how you're going to see the
world,
right?
That sets the sets,
the,
that sets the lens or it sets the frame
through which the world manifests itself
to you.
Right?
So it's as if you're getting your
spectacles adjusted properly and then
the world reveals itself to you and then
you use your language to articulate
that.
And that's,
that's the,
um,
that's naturally.
It's not,
it's not natural.
It's very.
Now you know,
if you don't do that,
what you do is end up.
You end up using your language to
manipulate people into giving you what
you want.
And that's not helpful because,
you know,
what do you know about what you want?
Give me one second.
Okay,
sorry about that.
My son,
my son's basement.
My house is being renovated in Toronto
for well til this afternoon and he's got
a new puppy and he was rolling a bone
upstairs on the floor for this puppy is
very cute by the way.
This puppy that's making quite a lot of
racket.
So I just had to take care of that.
Um,
so just give him a good cuff and.
No,
I just asked him.
I just told him that the ball was
rolling around,
so
look,
part of this is faith and truth.
You know,
like really it's hard to.
It's hard to emphasize this.
Importantly enough.
You have to make a decision in your life
at some point.
Look about how you're going to use your
words.
You can use them instrumentally and you
can use them to manipulate people.
You say,
well,
this is what I want from this situation
and here's how I'm going to have to
craft my words to get it.
Or you can think,
oh,
I'm oriented properly in the world and
I'm going to save what I think and let
things happen,
and those are two different.
They're really two different modes of
being.
I wrote about this in 12 rules for life.
They're really two different modes of
being and the latter,
the latter one,
which is faith and truth as the same as
faith in the logo,
spite away from a symbolic perspective.
It's the faith.
That truth is that which turns
uninhabitable.
Chaos into habitable order.
It's the truth that does that,
and so you,
you tell the truth and you throw caution
to the wind.
It doesn't mean you tell the truth
stupidly because telling the truth
stupidly isn't truthful.
You have to do it very carefully and
very strategically,
strategically,
well,
and the strategic part,
the goal is to get better all the time
at carefully articulating what
constitutes the truth.
You know,
it seems obvious to me in some sense.
It's like you got to really think this
through.
It's like,
what do you want on your side?
You want false hood on your side.
It's like,
who thinks that you really,
that you're going to be able to lie and
manipulate your way through the world
and that you're going to get away with
that,
but there's an arrogance that goes along
with that arrogance in belief,
that arrogance of belief in your
capability to deceive and that you're
going to pull the wool over everyone's
eyes,
right?
You're going to deceive yourself because
you're going to believe in your own
maliciousness and mendacious snus.
You're going to deceive other people
because they're stupid and they won't
catch on and you're going to see you're
going to deceive God and reality itself
because it's not going to snap back and
take you out if you bend and distort it,
like that's so foolish.
You don't have a hope,
none of that.
You might get away with your lies for a
certain amount of time,
but they're going to aggregate and take
you out and at every level,
not least,
your own guilt in your own self
contempt.
And so,
so where was that?
Well,
that's good answer to that question.
I agree.
We don't live in into radical patriarch.
Can you provide a better explanation for
the iniquities women face,
especially lateness of the right to
vote,
et cetera.
Well,
you know,
130 years ago,
let's say,
let's take $8,
95,
just as a starting point.
The world wasn't the same place as it is
now.
You know,
rights and privileges spread as the
social and economic conditions make
their manifestation possible to some
degree to some degree.
Um,
and I'm not suggesting that men have
oppressed women and the women have been
oppressed man Christ,
we've been at each other's throats in
many ways throughout the entire course
of human history.
Men that the throats of men,
men at the throats of women,
women at the throats of men,
women at the throats of women,
parents at the throats of children,
like there's no shortage of
contentiousness and tyranny that
characterizes human history.
So,
but
in 18,
95,
the average person in the western world
lived on less than a dollar a day in
today's money way below the current UN
standards for poverty.
Life was very,
very hard.
There was no reliable birth control.
Like you can't underestimate the radical
consequences of reliable birth control
now that,
that,
that opened up the world to women and
it's not just birth control,
it's a whole variety of technological
transformations.
And,
and also an increase in the safety of
the street to a hundred.
I'm contributing factors that opened up
the world to the freedom of women.
But a huge part of that was the
collective
striving of men and women to free
themselves from the absolute tyranny of
hand to mouth existence.
You know,
a woman was,
well,
let's say sexually mature back at that
time around 15 or 16,
very likely to be married soon after
that.
I'm partly because sex outside of
marriage was so unbelievably dangerous,
very high probability of pregnancy and
then of death in childbirth and then it
and then death of children,
and then continual pregnancy.
Women weren't the same even biologically
speaking,
that the birth control pill is a
biological revolution and it took a long
time to extend the full codery of rights
to people.
Even man.
It was like Jesus.
Most men in eastern Europe,
for example,
were serfs until the late 18 hundreds.
Fundamentally slaves.
It's,
it's,
it's not as if the common person has had
the right to vote for any substantial
amount of time in some countries for a
couple of hundred years and that's all
like were,
were,
were clambering out of the great
darkness of,
of biological history and creating a
culture where people have enough freedom
to be to exercise.
What would optimally be their full set
of rights and to say that that didn't
happen at the pie in the past,
primarily because of the Patriarchal
Dominion of men is I think an escape
from full confrontation with the
absolute dreadful horror of biological
history.
It's an.
It's a wish that all of the things about
life that are deeply troublesome and
terrible are a consequence of the errors
made by those who control the social
structure and God,
it would be really something if they had
that much power.
You know,
it's like,
well,
we can make things bad or good by women
by Fiat.
It's like,
no,
you're,
you're facing the terrible dragon of
nature and she's something awful to
behold and you're,
you're,
you're tyrannical.
Patriarchy is a relatively ineffective
forest in the face of the absolute
depredations of Mother Nature.
I mean,
even now,
we're powerful technologically compared
to how we have been in the past and you
know,
we've extended our life a lot,
but we still only manage about 80 years
and lot of that is still characterized
by my mental and physical illness.
You know,
we're still subject to the limitations,
that awful limitations of biology ways
that are almost too terrifying to be
hold.
And so we we shy away from that and say,
well,
it's all,
all the suffering as a consequence of
something that's oppressive and under
the control of human beings.
So like I know I wish that was the case,
but it isn't.
And that's not to say that social
structures lack corruption,
but
it's not as if 150 years ago all men
were free and all women were enslaved.
The truth of the matter is 150 years
ago,
virtually everyone was enslaved.
So and it,
it's,
it's a long bloody hole out of that.
You don't want a tremendous amount of
that has taken place over the last 130
years with the absolute revolution in
living standard and an availability of
food and proliferation of consumer items
and the,
the,
the construction of the formulation of
labor saving devices.
You know,
that that freed women from the grinding
misery of constant domestic work for,
for tens of hours a week at
extraordinarily low pay.
And the and the,
the provision of a
universally accessible hygienic
facilities,
toilets everywhere is a big deal.
It allows people to move around and to
operate out in the world and,
and tampons and sanitary products and
birth control and all of that.
Jesus,
women were oppressed because people were
oppressed and perhaps women were more
oppressed than men,
although even that's not obvious because
you know,
men suffered brutally in warfare,
absolutely,
brutally,
and,
and died at a,
at a rate.
Um,
if you eliminate child birth,
deaths from the equation died at a rate
that exceeded the rate that women died
at and we're required to sacrifice
themselves for the protection of women
and children.
It's like human history is a nightmare
and that nightmare involves
incredible difficulty in struggling for,
to survive.
And we emerged out of that men and women
together and have been attempting to
free each other to the degree that
that's possible in the course of that
struggle.
And so that's how it looks to me.
You have talked about earning your
knowledge.
How do you define man?
You guys?
You put up some viciously good questions
today.
Man.
I got to say,
these are tough questions.
They're very good question.
So this is devin amp.
You've talked about earning your
knowledge.
How do you define this and earn it?
When is it okay to debate ideas like
yours?
If they are not your own?
Well,
I would say it's okay to debate them
right away if what you're trying to do
is to test them and learn more about
them.
Right?
But it's not okay if you're trying to
put them forward as if they're your own
and to obtain something approximating
unearned moral superiority by doing so.
So that means to have the ideas and to
discuss them,
not to identify with them as if they are
defining characters that defining
features of your own personality,
how do you earn knowledge
well and allow your elementary school
teachers,
when you're writing an essay,
he said you got to put it in your own
words.
Think,
well,
what does that mean?
You can't just copy a sentence.
It has to be in your own words.
And you know,
to me that was never very well explained
to me,
but there was something to it.
It's like
for knowledge to be yours,
you have to integrate it with your own
experience.
You have to see how that applies to your
own case and then have a story to tell
about how that's the case.
That's personal,
right?
So it's the intermingling of the
abstract with the personal that makes it
real.
It's the intermingling of the epic with
the particular or the archetipal with
the,
with the concrete that makes something
real,
and so if an idea is still an
abstraction,
if you're just parroting it and it also
means that you haven't learned to use it
as a tool,
you haven't started to apply it in your
own life because you could say,
well,
here's an idea that I came across and
here's how I implemented it and here's
what I learned when I implemented it,
and then that's definitely yours,
right?
Because you're and you can kind of tell
because you're recounting your knowledge
in a manner that no one else could do
it,
and that's what gives it that ring of
genuineness,
right?
That's what it means in some sense,
to speak from the heart.
It's like,
well,
here's my experience with this idea and
you can say to,
well,
here's how I understand this idea,
and you read,
formulate that in your own terms and
that means that you associate it with
your own,
with the own union,
with the unique particularities of your
own experience.
And then I would also say it means that
you've acted out the ideas and tested
them like in,
in the world,
and that you have your own stories to
tell about that and that's how you make
it your own.
It's like you go to the tool store,
the hardware store,
and you buy a hammer,
you know,
and then you start to use the hammer to
hammer in nails and you learn how to use
the hammer.
You learn how to use the saw and then
you know,
at some point that saw sort of becomes
yours.
You know how to use it.
And it's the same with these ideas.
It's like you don't just,
you don't just say the words.
You're not just a puppet mouthing the
words.
It becomes part and parcel of your own
philosophy,
the way that you perceive the world.
The way that you construe things in the
way that you act in the world,
you've tested them and you have your
own.
You have something to add to them.
That's yours personally.
You know,
and if you.
If you're having a discussion with
someone and they're talking about things
that don't have those characteristics,
right,
that they haven't made personal,
then the conversation is almost never
interesting.
It's because the person is.
It's just an.
They're just.
They really are an empty shell through
which
ideologues etiology,
cliches and slogans are pouring.
There's nothing about that that's
compelling because you don't see the
grappling.
You don't see that the other person has
grappled with the ideas and come to
their own unique conclusions and it
really is in that mingling of the
abstract and the particular.
That compelling wisdom is to be found
and so that's,
that's and then concretely speaking,
well,
there's ways of earning your knowledge
and part of that is reformulating it in
your own words.
That's thinking it through,
right?
And discussing it until you have it at
hand.
You can talk about it and you can
generalize from it because you truly
understand it,
but a huge part of that is also putting
it into practice and driving your own
conclusions as a consequence.
And some of that can be done with
debate.
It's like,
here's an idea.
I came across and here's the idea and
here's what I think it means and this is
how I think it would change things if I
put it into practice,
this is how I understand this idea and
what do you think of that?
Like that's a good debate or discussion,
you know,
because then the other person can say,
well,
I don't really agree with the way you
formulated that or I don't agree with
your conclusions and hopefully it's a
real discussion and not just one
upmanship,
you know,
because that's a pretty dull game and
then,
oh,
then you get clearer about what it is
that the idea is and how it is that you
would use it as a tool in your own life.
And that's the right way to think about
ideas to.
Well,
partly they're,
they're tools for looking at the world
with because you have to look at the
world with tools because you can't look
at the whole world,
so you're looking at the world through a
tool like structure and then the ideas
themselves are tool like and they need
to be used and worn a bit in your hands
before their,
before their years.
So have you ever thought about engaging
in a public debate with Slavoj
[inaudible] Jack,
he has many interesting observations on
the topic of videology and that would be
a good conversation conversation.
Yes.
We have a tentative,
we haven't been speaking tentatively
about the possibility of having a
discussion in Toronto in April.
And so,
um,
we're negotiating and um,
we'll see how that goes.
We'll see if he's available and if I'm
available,
if we can agree on a set of topics,
if we can,
if we can undertake all the complex
detailed negotiations necessary to make
something like that successful in the
public sphere.
Um,
I'm confident enough that this will
occur,
that I've already done downloaded about
six of his books because I really want
to start understanding what he has to
say and think before undertaking that.
So,
so yes,
I've thought about it more than thought
about it.
The offer is out,
the negotiations are underway.
How do you maintain a stable identity
when you are plagued by bouts of
depression and anxiety?
Well,
the first thing we might say is that you
can't,
you know what I mean?
If you're playing by boats of depression
and anxiety,
that does destabilize your identity.
So,
um,
it's almost by definition,
but having said that,
look,
this is when habit and plan
and strategy are so useful.
So in the periods of depression that I
had,
what sustained some of them were long
and,
and certainly the most unpleasant
experiences of my life.
Um,
you,
this is when you need a philosophy,
let's say that's aligned with your
vision and your strategy to sustain you
because what would,
what would happen to me is that I know I
have these,
a vision and I suppose the vision is of
a world that's better in,
in it's less likely to descend into
ideological catastrophe and where people
are more responsible and more awake and
more educated and,
and,
and healthier,
all of that,
a vision of a better world,
you know,
a world that's less hellish at least,
but also a better world and some sense
of what role I might play in that.
And,
and so that's very motivating.
Like it's a profound goal too to try to
make things better.
And you can do that locally.
You can do that for yourself,
you can do that for your family,
you can do that for the broader
community and all of that.
It's worth it,
man.
It's worth making some sacrifices for.
It's worth suffering for to some degree.
And then you decompose that into the day
to day and week to week strategies and
actions that you're undertaking the
plans.
And,
and,
and the activities that you're putting
forward to make that dream a reality,
to realize it.
And then when the depression and anxiety
come along,
you think part of it with depression,
it's like it's just bloody endurance.
It's like get up and you work through
the next hour.
You try to stay on track,
you try to implement your strategic
plans to the best of your ability and
you hope and you pray that you'll get
through it.
You'll get through it and that the
darkness will recede and you,
you,
you stay on track,
you eat even though you're not hungry,
you get off.
Even though you want to stay in bed,
you interact with people even though
you'd rather be alone.
And it's,
it's,
it's the benefit of discipline habits
can,
can sustain you.
It's like the boat,
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm,
leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed,
but you have the boat and you can roll
forward and that's what you've got.
And so when durance is a huge part of
it,
and then I would say with it's anxiety,
it's the same thing.
It's like are very much the same as
you're terrified and and uncertain,
but you move ahead to the best of your
ability and again,
you operate at least to some degree on
hope and if you haven't got hope,
then you've got blind bloody endurance
and that's all motivated by some sense
that you're working towards something
that's worthwhile working toward,
you know,
and that is while that's your own
longterm wellbeing,
to treat yourself properly,
it's the stability and productivity and
harmony and health of your family.
That's a huge deal.
And then it's whatever benefit you can
be to the community and if you have to
limp along and drag yourself forward in
order to maintain that pathway,
then so be it because it's better than
the alternative.
So,
and I'm not,
and I know that you can become depressed
enough so that you know you're virtually
a mobilized,
but you do what you can to fight it and
you,
and then you do what you can to treat
it.
You know,
it's like,
have you tried antidepressants?
Have you gone to speak to a
professional?
Have you done what you need to do to
investigate?
The causes of your depression and
anxiety because often there's physical
reasons that that might be the case.
You know,
like I've learned notoriously that a
fair bit of the negative emotion that I
experienced to seem to be associated
with an auto immune problem that was
associated with food sensitivity.
Jesus.
Like I hadn't,
I would have never believed that was
possible 10 years ago.
Even though I did.
I had learned by that point that my
susceptibility to negative emotion was
definitely exacerbated.
For example,
if I was hungry,
so I knew there was some relationship
with food,
but I had no idea that it was as
profound as it turned out to be.
And so,
but don't.
And then.
Well,
the other thing you can do too is that
as the negative emotion ramps up in
intensity,
the amount of time you construe as
manageable shrinks,
you know,
and if you're extremely depressed and
anxious that you know,
you may be struggling to get through the
day and then you need a map of what is
going to constitute a minimally
acceptable day.
And that might be one where you'd done
what you need.
So that when you wake up to moral,
things aren't worse,
right?
You have to keep up with your
obligations and your duties at least
enough so that you're not degenerating
downhill.
And
Yeah,
the other thing too is that you,
you also learn that you act out the
things that you would do when you're
normal.
Even when you're depressed,
you know you don't want to see people.
Well,
it doesn't matter you go see them
because it's better than not seeing
them.
You know,
when you find,
when you do see them that it's better,
it'll go better than you think,
but you can't isolate yourself and
you're anxious and so you want to avoid.
You don't want to go out.
You'd rather stay home and sit in the
chair and just sit there and like in a
frozen position,
it's like you can't do that.
You have to go out and go grocery
shopping and go out and have coffee and
all of those things.
It doesn't matter whether you enjoyed
the,
it matters that you do them because
that's what you do.
That's what you do in order to maintain
your health.
And,
and so a huge part of it is like head
down in Durham and that'll get you
through bad times.
That endurance,
it's,
it's such an under represented virtue
that ability to trudge forward under a
trudge forward,
unhappily under a unfairly burden.
Some loan is a testament to character if
you can,
and it's something that should be
encouraged and valued.
So you know,
and I'm not making the claim that people
who are depressed who can't get out of
bed lack endurance,
some do and some don't because
depression comes in very varied degrees
of intensity in and you can be laid out
completely or depression.
So I'm not trying to make some arbitrary
judgment about who's gone into Europe
and who hasn't.
You can't do that from outside.
But I can say that endurance is one of
the tools you have to deal with chronic
discomfort and pain,
you know,
and even if you have chronic pain,
it's interesting because it's very much
allied with depression.
By the way,
all of the research on chronic pain,
back pain,
for example,
indicates and chronic pain have all
sorts is that the more you allow your
pain to render,
you inactive,
the worst outcome,
including exacerbation of the pain and
depression is a pain disorder.
And so that's very much worth thinking
about too.
It's like move forward,
move forward,
move
you know,
and if you need to talk to somebody
about what your plan is for the day or
the hour or the week,
then do that as well.
And perhaps you also have helped get the
people around you to help a bit.
I need a little bit of help getting up
in the morning.
I need to have breakfast made for me so
that all I do when I get up in my,
in my terrible state of fog and
confusion and terrible anxiety and
depression is I have a shower because
that's what happens first.
And then the next thing is I eat and
then that's better.
You're at least you're out of bed and
moving and that's,
that's a start.
You know,
so
and then you indira and hope and that's
how it is.
And you do the same thing when someone
in your family is sick or when you're
facing a death,
all of that.
It's like one bloody foot in front of
the other up the hill.
How are you always so consistently
composed and confident?
Yeah.
Well,
I wouldn't say that I am.
Um,
I know what you mean.
Well,
look,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not that young.
I'm just about 60 years old and so I
have a lot of experience behind me and
I've seen a lot of things and I've
learned to be detached to some degree,
you know,
that's one thing you learned as a
clinician as people are always talking
to you about terrible things and that
difficulties in their life and you can
take that home and have it destroy you
because you're constantly exposed to the
troubles of existence and they're real
troubles.
You know?
I mean,
it's not unique to clinicians.
You see that with physicians in
Palliative care workers and people who
work in morgues and emergency responders
and like there's lots of people who face
the,
the very difficult aspects of life very
frequently.
You detach yourself from it to some
degree,
you know,
and I don't mean in a disinterested way,
I mean in a,
in a way that is sort of allied with a
longer term view.
You know,
like if I'm doing an interview now with,
with someone who's attacking me and I
can get irritable.
I think I was too irritable in the Gq
interview,
for example,
which some of you might've watched.
I think,
well I'm not going to jump to
conclusions about how this is going to
go.
Even even with regards to how it feels
right in the moment.
We'll see how it unfolds across time and
I'll try to manage myself in the moment
with the least amount of upset that I
can manage.
And it's part of the doctrine of minimal
minimal necessary force.
One of the things I've learned,
if you're.
If you have a dispute with someone and
it needs to be settled and maybe they
need to change than you,
and that's not always the case because
sometimes the saddling requires change
on your part,
but let's say that they have to be
defeated in some sense in comparison to
you.
You don't want to defeat them any more
than necessary.
You know,
it's like you don't knock your opponent
to the ground and then jump up and down
on them three or four times in triumph.
You know,
you,
you pin them in London and then let them
up.
Minimal necessary force because any more
than that just produces a counter
reaction.
And so,
and I guess the other thing is too is my
motivation when I'm engaged,
let's say in these discussions,
is that I'm not trying to win the
argument.
I'm not trying to win.
I'm trying to say what I think as
clearly as I can.
And there is.
There might be an element.
There might be one of the consequences
of that might be what appears to be a
victory,
but
the victory is a victory for your
ability to articulate what you believe
and that's what I'm trying to do,
and so that's another reason to stay
composed.
It's like,
well,
okay,
this person has just thrown a curve ball
at me.
It's like,
all right,
so well
I could be thinking,
well,
I don't want to be undermined by that
and I don't want to make a fool of
myself and I don't want to be put on the
spot,
and of course all of those things are
true,
but mostly what I'm thinking about is,
okay,
well now I've got that question.
I want to answer as truthfully as I
possibly can.
What do I think about what was just sad
and I'm not calculating the outcome.
I'm assuming this is a mark of faith,
right?
This is the faith that that,
that people have talked about
being something that has to be
manifested necessarily.
It'd be talking about this since the
dawn of time.
What's the faith?
The faith is that if you say what you
believe to be true,
then whatever happens is the best thing
that could've happened,
and I believe that,
so that's what I really believe it
partly because I believe that if you're
deceitful,
which is the opposite of that,
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent,
but maybe primarily manipulative,
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will bring victory,
and I just don't believe that at all.
I.
I just,
I think it's a preposterous claim and
seek won't bring victory.
Then truth is what brings victory.
If there is such a thing as truth and
there's certainly such a thing as
deceit,
so there must be such a thing as.
And so some of it's just curiosity too.
It's like,
well,
I'm going to say what I think and see
what happens now.
It's an adventure.
You know,
that's the adventure of your life
really,
and you don't want to miss that because
that's what you've got in your life,
is for it to be an adventure.
It's not an easy road.
You know,
it's a stormy sea and what you have is
the adventure of contending with God and
the waves.
That's what you have and
the way you do that is with truth.
And then that sort of takes you out of
that
immediacy of the conflict.
Whoever it is that the conflict with
whoever it is that you're talking to,
you're trying to ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound and more
elastic.
Alright.
Like I don't think that I am pretty good
at it.
Consistently composed and confident,
you know,
I think I have faith in the truth.
Start the same thing and you know,
I'm an emotional person
obviously.
How do you manage to read so much?
Well,
a lot of that's good fortune,
you know,
like I seem to have a knack for reading.
It's not,
it was a gift.
You know,
like when I was a kid,
if I look at a word once,
I can always spell it like I have an
instantly.
And I've been like that ever since I was
little.
And so I seem to have a facility for
very rapid verbal comprehension and then
my father taught me to read when I was
very young and I think it was the
combination of those two things that
enabled that for me.
You know,
I had the natural proclivity of verbal
ability.
You know,
I,
my,
my graduate supervisor,
very smart guy,
Robert Peel Guy,
really liked,
he had trouble with spelling,
you know,
I don't know why that is.
People have different talents and I had
to tell it for immediate recognition and
memory of words and,
and,
and I'm also very verbally fluent.
Let me a sec here.
So I think mostly it's an innate talent.
Now I also do know that the more you
read,
generally speaking,
the faster you get.
Um,
my wife has really,
like,
she always read,
but she's really started to read more
since you've gone to Kendall.
She turns out she really likes her
kindle.
She reads a lot more in her reading.
Speed is increased.
A lot.
Lot of it's practice.
You can try to speed up your reading by
reading a little faster than you're
comfortable with
it.
I don't know the research literature
indicating the utility of that,
but practice is always useful.
The other thing is,
is that you want to make it part of
habit.
You both conceptually and practically a
lot of people don't read because they're
afraid of books.
Books aren't their friend,
so you might want to get a few books and
kind of make them your friend.
You can start with simpler books,
you know,
like fiction.
There's lots of good fiction writ
written for adolescents and children.
It's pretty straightforward when you can
start there if you're interested in
philosophy,
there's lots of simple guides like the
idiot's guide to,
um,
different topics or a beginner's guide.
I read those things all the time when
I'm first investigating a new topic,
you know,
I start with the introductory material,
um,
and I make time for reading,
like what was,
that was encouraged in my family.
Like I always read before I went to
sleep,
I read and I still do that.
I'm somewhat less so because I've become
so distracted by social media.
But,
uh,
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read.
And for me it was always just before I
went to bed,
I go to bed,
turn on the light and read for when I
was a kid for hours,
but and if you do something every day
you do a lot of it.
And so I would say,
well,
if you want to read,
if you want to make yourself educated is
put aside 20 minutes a day to read or
10,
you know,
some small amount of time that you could
actually steal.
Not Two hours because good luck,
man.
It's very unlikely you'll manage that.
But 20 minutes a day,
you know,
that's two hours a week.
That's 700 hours a year.
You know,
that's even if you're a slow reader,
that's a good number of books.
And so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value.
You investigate carefully what
resistances you might have to that idea
because you might think,
well that's a pseudo intellectual or
there's something more productive I can
be doing.
Or I'm intimidated by books,
or I hate books because I wasn't good at
reading when I was a kid and I was
humiliated because of it.
Or you know,
you've got something against
intellectuals or God,
there might all sorts of resistances to
picking up a book and then you could
listen to audio books.
That's a good way around that by hook or
by Crook,
man,
so you value it.
You make it a regular part of your life.
You practice doing it and you need a
higher goal too is like,
well,
why should you read well and so that
you're more informed and you can better?
Why should you be more informed and
think better because you won't walk
blindly into so many pits.
You know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more informed and more verbally fluent
and you'll have a better sense of how
the world works and be able to hold your
own in conversations and that'll make
you more confident.
Those are all unbelievably good reasons
to be highly literate.
This is an incredibly massive,
massive advantage.
Practical advantage,
you know,
and it shouldn't be underestimated.
So
there are many drug addicted mentally
ill homeless people in my city and it
seems to keep getting worse.
How do we help people who don't want to
be helped?
Well,
I think you do that by example.
Fundamentally.
Um,
there isn't any other way I know of,
to help people who don't want to be
helped.
And then I guess I think what you do is
you open up you,
it's the same thing I've said many times
is that
you do what you can to make the things
around you better,
you better your family better.
And then whatever you can manage in your
community know if you're interested in
drug addicted and mentally ill know
there are volunteer,
you can volunteer,
you can talk to those people and listen
because then you'd find out what the
hell their problems are and then you'd
have some sense about how they might be
helped,
you know.
But that's a hard thing.
There's no helping from above
drug addiction and its combination with
mental illness.
Unbelievably complicated problems.
There's no simple solutions.
So.
And it isn't even necessarily obvious
that the people that you see who are
homeless and drug addicted mentally ill
don't want to be helped,
is that sometimes they have problems
that are so absolutely overwhelming that
they can't be helped in any real sense.
You know,
like if they're unmedicated
schizophrenia for example,
with a drug problem,
Scott,
it's just,
it's just a nightmare.
It's a nightmare of insane complexity
because schizophrenia is very,
very difficult to deal with even even
with medication because the medication
that helps people who are schizophrenia
also tends to depress their positive
emotion and decreased their motivation.
You know?
So the medications are generally helpful
and the proper treatment guidelines if
your schizophrenia generally are stay
with your medication because despite the
negative consequences of the medication,
which aren't trivial,
the consequences of not taking it or
worse.
And that's a real Hobson's choice,
right?
It's a bit of hell in both directions.
But if you really want to know,
I would say
go have some contact with those people
and listen to them and learn what the
problems are.
Maybe you could start seeing what might
be helpful.
It's a really complicated problem and
it's different than the problem of
helping people who don't want to be
helped because you have to figure out
who it is that that doesn't want to be
helped first and you don't want to
assume that just because someone's
homeless that they don't want to be
helped.
I mean that doesn't mean that it's easy
to figure out how to help them.
It's not easy.
It's helping people is a very difficult
business and it's a very dangerous
business too because you get tangled up
in ways that you wouldn't expect and
that can be an occupational hazard.
Let's put it that way.
How do I stop ruminating?
These thoughts are recurring and relate
to every and any embarrassing moment
I've ever had during my lifetime.
I'm a 76 year old woman.
Well,
here's something you could try.
Write down everything that you're
ruminating about.
I know that seems counterproductive,
but like see,
ruminations come up accidentally in
voluntarily,
unconsciously.
Whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about your facing
them voluntarily,
so I would say,
well,
open up a journal or word document,
whatever,
and write down every time you ruminate
about something,
write it down and write down every
rumination you can remember exhaustedly,
write them all down.
That would be the first thing.
Then the second thing is standard
behavioral therapy practice.
The second thing,
the next thing would be,
um,
write down why you think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you
might've done about them then,
but more importantly,
what you could do about them in the
future to avoid that because it doesn't
matter that something embarrassing
happened to you once.
What matters is whether or not you're
likely to repeat it in the future,
but my suspicions are that even if you
just,
you could just start sampling.
Write down every ruminating,
ruminating thought that you have
voluntarily and think about them in
detail and write them down in detail.
Get every little word down and then you
have that document.
And then when you have a thought and
start to ruminate on it,
um,
then sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily.
So every time you ever thought you don't
want to have later practice having that
thought on purpose and try that for
about a month and see what happens
because it's often the case that if you
start thinking about the thoughts,
you're ruminating on consciously and
confront them voluntarily,
that they will start to go away.
So you could try that.
You could try that.
That should help.
What's the best method to retain what
you read and to be able to use it in
conversation.
Oh,
well
it's very difficult really to retain
anything without recalling it.
So look,
if you encounter something
and then you encounter it again,
you can usually recognize that you've
encountered it before.
That's recognition memory.
So it's,
it's an important form of memory.
It's,
it's,
it's the memory that's associated with
familiarity,
but it's not the same as being able to
use something.
Exactly.
It's a rather shallow form of memory
even though it's necessary in order to
be able to use something.
You have to recall it.
This is also very useful hint for
studying.
If you're studying and you have to
remember what you want to do is study,
and then you want to write down what you
just learned.
So you read the paragraph,
he closed the book,
and you write down what you remember or
you read a chapter and you close the
book and you write down what you
remembered.
Or at least you sit there and you try to
remember because the way you remember is
by practicing remembering.
Okay?
So if you're reading and you want to use
it in conversation and you have to think
about what you read,
you have to put it in your own words.
It's often helpful to close the book and
write it down or to associate it with
some problem that you're currently
trying to solve.
Do you have to take the knowledge and
make it your own and then.
And then that alters the structure
through which you look at the world and
that changes the way that you think,
so that when you have a conversation the
next time that you're going to have the
conversation in a different way.
So merely reading isn't enough.
You have,
you have to read and think and recall
and it's the act of recalling that
produces the remembering and it's that
act of remembering that puts that
material at hand for you.
So.
Okay,
well look,
I'm just about done here.
It's 1135,
so I've gone for 19 minutes and I hear
people rattling room upstairs and I have
to fly dessert today.
And so I'm going to start out.
I'm going to stop.
I'm here,
so I'll find one more question and
answer it.
And then,
um,
I just found out I'm having a girl.
Congratulations.
What can I do to raise her to think for
herself and not fall into the modes of
thinking proposed by popular culture?
Well,
you can let her think for herself when
she's a kid.
You know,
what you do is so that she practices
doing that,
you know?
Um,
and so that means two
consciously encourage as much autonomy
as possible.
So how do you do that?
Well,
let's say she's a little kid,
she's three and she started to get
interested in clothing.
So you lay clothing out of the bed and
you say what?
You can wear this or you can wear this.
You let her make autonomous decisions.
You know,
with kids,
you don't want to let them choose from
an infinite menu.
You want to give them a constraint menu.
But what you want to do with your
daughter is allow her to make as many
decisions as she can possibly make as
early as possible.
You know,
and that doesn't mean the children
always know what's best for themselves
or any nonsense like that.
It just means that you're going to
encourage her autonomy to every,
in every
measure that you can manage.
And that means you're going to have to
be brave and allow her to subject
yourself to a certain number of risks.
So you,
you,
you raise her to think for herself by
letting her think for herself.
And that can start.
That can start quite early.
I would say when she's a teenager,
she's going to fall into the modes of
thinking proposed by popular culture
because that's part of being
enculturated socialized.
It's virtually inevitable and it's even
somewhat desirable,
but what you hope is that you've.
You've encouraged the capacity for
autonomous thinking to a sufficient
degree that it's likely to integrate
with that more intense teenage
socialization and then reemerge.
So you get someone who comes out the
other side as an autonomous individual
and that works with boys and girls.
So.
So you know,
let's,
I guess you do.
What Japan did in Pinocchio is the first
thing you decided is,
well,
you don't want to raise a puppet.
Don't you want to raise an autonomous
person,
and and then you think through what does
it mean to be an autonomous person?
What sort of person do you want your
child to be?
What,
what sort of person do you want to
encourage your child to be?
And then having,
having,
having established that vision in mind,
that's going to guide your choices,
but at least you're making the right
choices.
You don't want someone who's dependent
and whiny and clingy and and,
and more frightened than they need to be
and martyr martyr like and vengeful and
malicious and manipulative and
mendacious.
All of those states.
You want someone who can make their own
judgements and you can ask kids what
they think pretty damn early,
like you have to be careful and not push
them beyond their capacity,
but
if you know your child,
you will be able to see what level of
decision making they're capable of
engaging in and then you would encourage
them to mature as rapidly as they can.
You know,
and that also means that you have to not
allow yourself to fall too in love with
a dependent and needy creature that your
infant will be to fulfill your own
emotional needs.
You want to detach and encouraged to
mature as rapidly and as comprehensively
as possible.
And that will work,
you know,
and some of that,
some of that is
negotiation with your child and find out
what they think.
It's like,
what do you think about this?
What do you think about who should do
the work in the house?
How should we split it up like they can
be engaged in the decision making?
Process is a very early age and and part
of that,
that encouragement is going to be
reflected in your implicit attitudes
that the child is a real person who's
capable of imposing their will
in a realistic sense,
one in the world on the world and doing
that in a competent and
excuse me,
competent and confident manner so,
but at least the beginning is the desire
to do that.
You want to raise them confident,
autonomous,
courageous,
truthful person,
and then you reward them when they're
like that and you notice it and you tell
them good work.
You did that,
right?
Keep it up.
That's the right thing.
And you tell them why.
What they did was right,
you know,
in a detailed way.
And that's very powerful.
You wait and you look and you wait for
something that you want to have happened
and you say,
yes,
we'd like to see a lot more of that good
work.
You do that with yourself and with your
partner to very powerful technique.
All right everyone,
I'm going to say goodbye.
Um,
hopefully I'll do another one of these
in February,
although I'm not certain maybe at the
end of January I have a couple of days
there,
but I'm going to Australia in February
and that's going to be very busy.
So,
but maybe I can do I like doing this.
Maybe I can do another one in January
near the end.
Um,
so,
uh,
just one last thing,
I just want to let everybody know,
remind everybody that I am leaving
patrion on the 15th of January.
And so,
um,
thanks for your support over the last
couple of years and,
um,
hopefully,
hopefully my next book will be better
than the last one was.
That's the plan that I'm doing my best
to manage that and uh,
and hopefully we'll all have a good
year,
you know,
and aim high and all of that.
So good to see you.
Um,
and we'll talk in something
approximating a month.
Bye Bye.